[Music]
new ones - this is take these five
different most striking differences that
you are voted on when you register it
and have a debate on each one and I want
to stress it the purpose of these
debates it's not like a presidential
debate where the goal is to try to
humiliate the other side or get it the
point is or the point is rather simply
to make sure all of us get to hear what
the interesting arguments are for each
position and see if we can get a more
nuanced way of thinking about these
things and all of the five panels we're
gonna have now in rapid succession will
not only debate those positions that
were in the survey but each panelist is
gonna propose a little bit more nuanced
position that they like and then you
will get their way in and say how
enthusiastic you are on each one of
those so without further ado we're gonna
go to the the very first panel which
will be chaired by joi Ito from MIT our
director of the media lab and we have
chair Hyun y1 and Tanya Singh and John
havens and Kathryn Olsen and joi Ito who
are gonna debate should we build super
intelligence
so I want each of you to give a one or
two minute non nuanced very sort of
specific view of why you chose yes or no
and then we're gonna do this for the
polling but I want you to either name or
describe what your position is because
we're gonna then do a popularity contest
later about maksud it wasn't a
competition but we'll see what the
distribution of the audience is and how
compelling your vision is but the vision
so the first part is do a non nuanced
pitch of your vision and then the last
half we're gonna have a conversation to
then have the more nuanced conversation
about the details and so try to be as
Extreme as you can without being wrong
and then after you guys each speak I'll
give a orthogonal but hopefully useful a
little comment and then we'll open it up
to conversation so that's that's sort of
the lay of the land so I'll start out
with you Katherine cool so of course the
word should has a lot of meanings when I
answered this question initially I tried
to take a pretty pragmatic stance on it
like if a friend came to me who I
thought was like a capable friend who
might actually do things in the world
and said my plan is to build a company
or to start a company and we're going to
build super intelligence should I do
that and say ah no like sounds like
there's some other things you should
consider in that so that's sort of a
sort of direct pragmatic should argument
or should not argument the question is
should we build super intelligence I'll
highlight we already have systems that
are super intelligent on specific tasks
we've already done that in certain
domains so maybe you interpret the
question as should we build fully
autonomous agents that exceed human
capacity in pursuing their goals and a
reasoning and sort of a long-term
consequentialist way I think sort of the
whole point of this conference is that
we all broadly agree that would go very
badly by default so no we shouldn't do
that and then to sort of put the like
punchy analogy on it when I was talking
with some of these folks before of
course there would be a lot of benefits
we could attain if we could do this
right whatever doing it right means the
analogy being okay the pool is really
nice I'd like to give swimming in the
pool there I would have a lot of fun but
the pool is full of sharks like it's
full of sharks
should I go swimming in the pool the
answer is no there's things we could do
to mitigate those risks but right now I
think the risk pool of sharks pool of
sharks okay okay hi John it's like a TV
show so I'm John and I say this just
speaking for me down I Tripoli or the
council on extended intelligence the
stuff I do mine is also kind of a shark
in the pool analogy and it's somewhat
nuanced in the sense that I don't think
we should do anything not just a GI
until we figure out the economic
paradigm ik level underpinnings of most
of what we do as humans and I was in
Korea about a month ago at the OECD
well-being workshop which is about 700
statisticians around the world focusing
on things like the UN s DG's and how
what we're actually measuring as a sense
of what brings humans worth and
prosperity since the 40s and 50s is
largely about GDP GDP is not evil if you
hear the term GDP and Beyond it means
there are other measures that we can use
to understand both human and
environmental flourishing so for me one
thing to keep in mind if you study GDP
which is riveting and fascinating I'm
kidding is it's really about
productivity looking back on a year and
it's also about measuring things like
exponential growth well in terms of
values alignment when you have systems
that are designed to be sometimes very
fast and to do things at an exponential
rate and then you have a measure of
success a key performance indicator that
for both policymakers and business I
used to be an EVP of a top 10 PR firm
and every quarter when the doors closed
you would want to bring value to your
customers you would want to do stuff
that would help the world but you also
said these are the five words that
dictated the actual actions you took did
we make our numbers so beyond GDP means
people planet profit if we can have
triple bottom-line economic metrics
guiding what we make for Ag eyeness ASI
I'm diving in the pool sharks are known
without them I don't think it makes
sense to move forward without really
thinking what is prosperity and
flourishing mean for people in the
environment and and the entities that
may come beyond if we don't deal with
that now
don't do it until we can measure it yeah
so GDP and Beyond would be I guess the
DPM joined
piffy not as good as sharks in the pool
thing thank you all right I'm approach
this question is that I feel the future
is with super intelligence I did have a
lot more positive values so it seems
that to me it seems that in so far is we
are not certain that the alignment
problem is intractable or super
intelligence will lead to some
devastating outcomes existential risk
level catastrophe for human beings
it seems our job is to grind down the
risk and bring it down to in fact
infinitely small basically and to say
that we're not sure whether we can do
that and there's risk hence we should
stop progress towards super intelligence
arguably you can't even do that but to
say that just stop progress towards
super intelligence to me seems like
you're throwing the baby out with the
bathwater and it's a really cool baby
because it can help you know mitigate
interest tential and risk or even
catastrophic risks from other advancing
technologies so to me seems like it's
it's slightly premature to say that we
shouldn't be progressing towards super
intelligence that's the spirit with
which I've approached the question I
think you can also frame the problem in
a way that our current level of
understand with our current level of
understanding we can say that super
intelligence could there is a
non-trivial chance that they'll be
extremely bad outcomes from it or that
the technology gets concentrated in the
hands of a few malicious actors or we
get locked in a highly suboptimal sort
of condition with our Axia logical
potential getting curtailed so all of
these are options on the table which we
need to explore and make sure that we we
don't run too much of a risk of those
things we don't run a risk of those
things but currently I don't think we're
in a position to make that call and it
seems a little premature to say that we
should close off we should close off
this path because you know and and not
explore all and not not try and reap all
the few positive outcomes that could
come out from this technology and build
offensively stable world which AI would
allow us to do don't throw out the baby
don't throw out the baby cook
right how to point for my position is
different with all of the three call it
that is absolutely we should yes so the
point is that first so the involvement
of the intelligence in the universe is a
very long trip so our human risk only
one stage one stop of the long trip no
reason to stop at our stage and we
prevent higher level in holidays is
Norina for me is a very natural
direction to be there for the super
intelligence and maybe somebody say we
can involve ourselves maybe we can
become smarter in the future but for our
humorous that means we need thousands of
years maybe longer because our brain our
body involved too slow and we have a
limitation of our scope example so it's
impossible for our human being to become
to become the super intelligence
compared with the machine based super
eNOS so if the future the sooner or
later so it will happen in some maybe
some filter so in this case no
difference to build super intelligence
yes or not because it will happen why we
with or delay the appearance of the
super intelligence so finally we need
face the the appearance the super
intelligence some some day so that's one
why we do we must prepare for the for
that the second point is that even from
the perspective of our human human
centered or human expert it's personal
leader
we still need to develop super
intelligence because we have so many big
challenges to face maybe for our human
race we cannot figure out that big
Helenus we need the help of interest for
example nuclear waste interest maybe
destroy our earth we know that but you
can think about if another small planet
hit our earth son someday without the
nuclear weapon we may become de venise
or so with super invaders means we can
solve some big challenges that our human
race cannot cannot do so we need to that
in the future and help us for me
the superintendence is not totally
different intelligence compared with us
is our copy but with fast
maybe powerful interest mr. Covey is
findable share the same neural network
in our brain so that means we can
communicate with several antennas we
built
it's not aliens so he is our could be
become our partner and it has our
intelligence so that's why I support the
short version would be something like
shouldn't slow the inevitable slowly we
shouldn't slow the inevitable how would
you summarize and something that goes on
the screen or is it we're just we don't
matter or matter we think about how to
it's the three words or would they be us
through water okay the way we should do
that we should just do it okay that's
good the I will make my slightly
orthogonal comment so some people
mentioned it but I think it should word
is kind of weird because if you don't
have the ability to
but there is no should it's just it will
happen so am i if I'm allowed to add one
I would say doesn't matter it will
happen but I'll also just point out I
think David Kruger said it earlier when
he was talking about the comprehensive
AI services I'm very much in his in the
camp of that conversation about AI
actually being agency and models that
are integrated into the system we use
the term extended intelligence so if you
think of corporations or society instead
of individuals we already have super
intelligence in a way that organizations
are arguably more intelligent at least
more complex than individuals and that
if we start to augment society rather
than think about augmenting individuals
it's already happening and it will
probably happen anyway and it's sort of
an unstoppable thing and so but I would
just have have question with the with
the framing but anyway um so so my thing
is that it will happen anyway and it's
already here and so should we do the
vote and then do the conversation how
can you have both it already happened
and it's inevitable
well so absolutely I'll just keep going
okay so I think I think what happens is
well we're just evolving on a tree
actually with increasing power and my my
view is that super intelligence is just
intelligence increasing at the societal
scale and that and a my etta thing is
that I think we just AI just makes us
more powerful and more complex careening
in the direction that we're going
so I'm more interested in getting our
house in order in our trajectory headed
the right way rather than figuring out
whether we should stop it or not that's
sort of my vote and then my nuance which
you will all get a chance to me wants
away are that are the unknowns multiple
choice I want to just pose a particular
framing of the question and I'm gonna
commit an error which I apologize for
which is like raise your hand if you
oppose me a question which I haven't
even spent five minutes thinking about
but it came up with it right before I
got on the stage which is let's say that
you are
Dennis Shane and Mustafa and you're the
heads of deepmind and one of your
engineers comes to you and is like we
can do it we can push the button we can
build a GI and it's right now like
January 1st or whatever January 4th 2019
and you're trying to ask the
okay should we do this thing how would
you tell what questions would you ask
what experts would you go to do you have
enough information to make the judgment
right now today if this were to actually
happen like yes we should and I don't
think that collectively we have the like
decision-making tools epistemic
institutional institutional sanity
technical safety work done such that
there's any person today that could make
the yes we should decision like right
now that's just like a little more
nuanced but I would encourage folks to
actually think like what would it take
for us to be in a world where a group of
people is actually making the decision
there's this thing build super
intelligence there's an action we can
actually take which is give the thumbs
up should we do it what would it take
for there to be a valid like yes answer
that we don't feel good about
yeah I'm just posing a question that I
think is like more meaningful than what
was asked or something or like maybe has
some more so so go on so adding the time
right now actually changes that makes it
more crisp right but I'm sort of say
imagine that this is happening right now
but then imagine like what properties
does a world have in the future that's
different than right now I don't think
anyone in this room maybe I'm wrong
would claim that like there's a possible
state where someone alive on earth could
like confidently press the Go button and
like be making the right call but what
would the world look like where that is
true
like what would those decision-makers
need to have access to that they don't
have access to right now okay can I keep
you in there yeah and do we have a mic
for anybody at this back yeah hi so I
was going to say something really naive
or maybe very unimaginative but I don't
know how to think of a world where
someone says I'm about to do a GI I can
push this button and it will happen
right now I don't have it already
but you know if I push this button I
will have it like can you tell us a
little bit more of what it would take to
get through that stage
yes it's impossible to push a button and
heaven tomorrow it's impossible for me
at least 30 yes so we have at least just
let me try to clarify I didn't mean
right now I just mean ok 30 years from
now how would we get into a stage where
someone was doing AI research raining
their stuff by supplying somebody award
functions playing around with things and
then all of a sudden were like oh we
don't have a GI but if I push this
button we will have a GI
what does push the button mean how I
already have it at the point where you
realize that if you push a button you
have it there's a like you max pick I
mean okay we before Justin it's so cool
party means at that time we have the
technology and the sister if we threw
the button the Adria maybe have it so
that is the that the time I think we're
at a time unfortunately maybe push the
button is like the last mile of things
that need to be done to develop yeah
just if you couldn't reframe it like
that it doesn't necessarily need to be
pushing this ability but yeah okay
thanks panelist thank you
[Applause]
[Music]